[Music]
foreign
do you have for someone getting started
in machine learning when we get started
the entrance to Ai and machine learning
was relatively narrow you almost have to
start from computer science but today I
actually see many years to come and more
and more that there is meaning aspect of
AI that creates entry points for people
from all walks of life for example my
colleague at HR are trying to find
answers on What does it mean when robots
software are participating in the
workflow more and more how do you
measure our economy that's not a i
coding question that is a AI impact
question it takes people together to
figure this out and also to use this new
tool as long as you're passionate about
this there's a role to play
[Music]